seitdem wir den eigenen Garten haben
wollte ich ein Gartenhaus bauen um drin
zu chillen mit Freunden abzuhängen zu
kochen und entspannt und naturnah am
Laptop zu arbeiten drum fangen wir jetzt
an mit der Planung der autarken
Gartenhütte samt Solarpanels und
Batteriespeicher dieses Video wird
unterstützt von Anker und der
empowerhouse 767 mit dem sämtliche
Elektrogeräte Nöte dank der hohen
Kapazität betrieben werden können mehr
dazu später also werden toll geil pass
auf die erste Idee die ist ja schon mal
richtig wählt und zwar irgendjemand
dieses Video gepostet was mega geil ist
weil er hat halt einfach in seiner Wand
so eine Art Aquarium nur halt mit Vögeln
aber halt in der Freiheit das heißt das
ist halt das draußen und das ist das
drin das hätte richtig gerne schon ein
bisschen Hütte und arbeitest du und
Tschüss so von wir haben da halt auch so
ein Grünspecht da draußen
okay
das wollte ich auch sagen
ja was noch klar Stromversorgung
solarpanelsystem natürlich nice Station
aufgeladen würde passend
hey wie geil hä wie cool und genauso
machen wir es das Anker power-haus kommt
in die Hütte und betreibt dann die
wilden Elektrogeräte die wir aufgelistet
haben seine 248 Wattstunden reichen z.B
um 33 mal unseren Laptop aufzuladen oder
zehn Tage durchgängig diese Stehlampe zu
betreiben auf dem Dach stehen dann zwei
Solarpanels damit das Powerhouse nicht
leer geht und selbst wenn es nach einem
entspannten Abend mal leer geht bei
Sonnenschein ist es damit schon in 5
Stunden 40 wieder voll und kann
natürlich während des Ladens schon
wieder genutzt werden 25 März bis 2
April gibt's bis zu 734 € Rabatt und
wenn ihr flott seid könnt ihr bis zum 19
März noch bei der Glücksrad Aktion
teilnehmen bei der ihr noch mal
zusätzlich bis zu 1250 € und top als
Rabatt bekommen könnt
richtig cool danke dir
bist du noch mit dem Design mitmachen
paar Sachen Brainstorm würdest du
streichen von der Farbe her oder würdest
Du
heutemäßig lassen und ich bin schon auf
den schreckdach eigentlich sowas finde
ich eher ja aber das tut schon geil aus
also rein optisch ist das schon heftig
also von vorne würde ich glaube sowas
nehmen oder sowas also wo bist du hin
bauen es gibt viel Auswahlmöglichkeit
also dann hier ist schon glaube ich ganz
gut aber das finde ich doch zu weit
unten also hier für mich tatsächlich
ziemlich nice und anhand der
ausgesuchten Stelle habe ich dann schon
mal eine grobe Skizze gemacht die ich
anschließend mit Mann und Pascal
gesprochen habe also hier ist der Hand
ne das Haus ich komme so ein Paar
Stelzen hin also das Problem ist jetzt
wenn man da mal ein bisschen
rauszukommen sieht das ungefähr so aus
ne und hier ist dann der Garten das ist
schon recht hoch also hier wird es
eigentlich echt gut anbieten ja genau
also hier so und das müsste halt noch
ein bisschen planiert werden weil ich
mache mal leider
richtig geil ihr macht ja richtig schön
in den Hand mit es wird ein tricky weil
den Bus glaube ich krieg der nicht mehr
so gut ich glaube dass er ein bisschen
verwirrt also sailing jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt weil das muss jetzt noch ein
bisschen Farbe Arbeiten der Scan ist
voll nice geworden man kann jetzt hier
tatsächlich einfach diese Oberfläche
sehen und wenn ich hier so ein Profil
drauf schaut dann kann man jetzt
theoretisch hoffentlich gleich ausmessen
wie hoch ist
anhand der sliderscans und meiner Skizze
hat sich Manu dann hingesetzt und unsere
Hütte in CAD modelliert
[Musik]
hältst du den also ich glaube dich
bisschen hoch ich glaube nicht gleich
mit rein einfach
[Musik]
Alter ist das viel Holz
gekostet glaub knapp 2000 oder so ja
cool jetzt Pascal alle Materialien
besorgt haben können wir auch schon mit
dem Bau loslegen als Fundament dienen
uns diese Einschlagbodenhülsen die wir
jetzt naja anschlagen
so der ist drin jetzt gerade sehr sehr
froh weil diese Teile haben so ungefähr
fünf Arbeitstage gespart weil eigentlich
wollten wir das da rein Betonieren dann
gehen wir jetzt hier 1,35 rüber das wird
jetzt auch nicht so präzise wie ich es
gerne hätte ja also wir haben erst alles
falsch geplant und dann ist man
hingefallen und hat jetzt eine komplette
wieder weg zu machen als das wert war
jetzt hat er verloren
[Musik]
Butter
die ganzen Pfosten sind mittlerweile
drin die müssen wir jetzt noch ein
bisschen fester reindonnern und dann
sind wir durch
[Musik]
die erdanke die wir gekauft haben die
haben 90 auf 90 Millimeter unsere Balken
haben aber 100 auf 100 das heißt ich
nehme jetzt von jeder Seite 5 mm weg und
dann sollten die perfekte in unsere Erde
passen natürlich nehme ich nicht vom
ganzen Balken halben Zentimeter ab
sondern eben nur von den Enten die in
den Boden angekommen und auch wenn das
mit dem Stemmeisen schon ganz gut
geklappt hat
einen Teil kriegt er doch auf die
Oberfläche umgestiegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
so und diese Teile
extrem schwer sind komm jetzt hier rein
und der den wir vorhin als Unboxing
benutzt haben der kommt da ganz oben hin
weil der wird später abgesägt
also ist es gerade der Laser
und der lasert hier die ganzen Pfosten
auch wenn ihr das jetzt nicht sehen
könnt wahrscheinlich sehe ich hier so
ein laserstrich so und da zeichne ich
jetzt den ersten Strich und damit ich
jetzt nicht jedes Mal von da oben bis
unten in die Werkstatt diese Riesen
fetten und schweren Plätze tragen muss
habe ich jetzt hier das Anker power-haus
mit dem ich ganz easy hier vor Ort die
2000 Watt kapsäge betreiben kann
so und schon ist vor Ort so ein Monster
Anteil durchgeschnitten hat auch mal was
draußen
[Musik]
man kann sich denken dass mit dem
Bauhaus deswegen so ziemlich alle
Haushaltsgeräte und Musikboxen von
unterwegs betreiben kann und ich kann
jetzt damit einfach wieder hochlaufen
der Kollege kommt hier rein ist denn
genauso hoch wie er hier ja und gleich
die nächste schneiden absolut krasses
Gerät hat bis zu 2,3000 Watt und 2048
Wattstunden und wenn so ein Schnitt hat
5 Sekunden dauert habe ich mal eben
ausgerechnet wird es reichen für 720 von
diesen absolut fetten 10 x 10 cm dicken
Holzbein wenn man fertig ist mit der
Arbeit macht man das integrierte Licht
aus und zieht das ankaufhaus wie ein
Koffer einfach weg auch auf unwegsamen
Gelände den Link dazu gibt's in der
Infobox also wir machen jetzt wegrennen
weil Manuel überzeugt dass diese
Japansäge hier äh für so einen fetten
besser geeignet ist also nur bis zur
Hälfte 3 2 1 1
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
werde euch die Toleranzen geplant da
oben ja genau so
ach nee
ja vorne ist perfekt ja also halt aber
da hinten dahinten und er dann in der
Mitte was macht er da nachdem dann die
spaltenmaße noch ein bisschen beglichen
wurden bekommt das meiste after
Fundament seine letzten Schrauben so
jetzt auch der Punkt an dem man diese
sollen aber fest spannen kann bis jetzt
waren die nämlich noch locker aber jetzt
war alles perfekt waagerecht ist
was machst
so das hält auf jeden Fall mal das ist
tatsächlich recht stabil ist jetzt die
Frage ob das noch die 500 Kilo Holz
aushält aber man kann auf jeden Fall ein
Schwindel erregen der Höhe
rumbalancieren okay das ist einmal hier
rein und er hier so hier ja
also diejenigen da draußen die Ahnung
von dem was wir machen ihr müsst jetzt
ganz stark sein so sieht übrigens mein
Bett aus
jetzt ziehen wir mal glaube ich langsam
welche Dimensionen das Haus annimmt
[Musik]
aus den der Redaktion nicht näher
bekannten Gründen müssen wir tatsächlich
jetzt umziehen wir müssen das ganze Teil
so wie es da steht weil der Runde tragen
klingt dumm ist auch so let's go
[Musik]
boah das Bremsen
ja genau
[Musik]
Fortschritt und jetzt ist der nächste
Schritt quasi den Boden einzulegen und
hier liegt jetzt schon mal so eine 2 cm
starke die wir ganz am Boden nutzen
wollen würden
und der nächste
so jetzt kann ich natürlich hier nicht
einfach noch eins reinlegen ist klar
weil der Platz ist halt immer zu klein
darum zeichne ich mir das jetzt mal an
das was hier ausgespart werden muss so
auf der Länge hier auch
und wahrscheinlich das aus
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich das hoffentlich
einfach problemlos reinlegen oha
tatsächlich muss das noch ein bisschen
nach unten geben Box werden
ja also ein schöner Preis bekommt nicht
aber das Boden
[Musik]
krank geworden deswegen haben leider
wurde der übel Manu und Pascal die Bude
jetzt fast fertig gebaut ist ziemlich
geil genau das einzige was jetzt darauf
fehlt so wie es von hier aussieht ist
die Außenverkleidung also das ist auf
jeden Fall das ist echt cool geworden
oder hey das ist halt echt riesig das
ist größer als meine erste Wohnung dann
machen wir jetzt mal die erste Außenwand
hier
ja Nut und Feder mal anders einfach hier
in dem Fall ohne Not der kommt dann auch
noch hinten glaube ich das Problem ist
Alter das 90 %
von diesem Brettern aber so kacke
gesehen dass wir die nicht vorne machen
wollen dieses Holz eigentlich so von
guter Qualität müssen unsere bezahlen
das ist gekauft haben so eher ein Loch
und das ist halt echt blöd weil dann
zieht halt einfach durch er hat halt
Abwechslung sogar einfach mal drei
Löcher ja also zwei von sechs Brettern
waren
ungefähr 5 mm zu mir okay Leute
[Musik]
einfach vielfach Verglasung ins
Gartenhaus Alter ich fühle mich gerade
einmal wie in so einem Film wo jetzt
gleich so ein Auto durchfährt also auf
jeden Fall eine geile Aussicht jetzt
dass da oben ist halt ja also dieser
Riss ich glaube wir werden irgendwann
diese Scheibe noch austauschen ja ein
bisschen Angst habe
[Musik]
das voll geil jetzt hält das schon und
jetzt hier oben noch einen drauf
[Musik]
die Angst dass ich jetzt gerade rein
boah und mir egal
[Musik]
jetzt fehlt eigentlich nur noch das Dach
und die Tür also ist ja schon hoch ne
auf jeden Fall komplett sicher was wir
machen noch nicht so sicher gefühlt in
meinem Leben wirklich entspannt ja voll
oder man
Thomas ein bisschen Schlagzeilen aber
ich mache das schon die maximalen Blitz
pro Minute kaputt
[Musik]
werden
[Applaus]
und wenn dir jetzt das Dach fertig
machen würde ich sagen mache ich gleich
den Balkon gerade weil wir sehen hier
ein paar kürzer und ein paar länger
[Musik]
und auf dieses Dach kam dann noch eine
Rolle von sogenannten Bitumen damit kein
Wasser reinregnen kann viel Arbeit war
dann auch noch dieser zugegebenermaßen
nicht komplett professionelle Türrahmen
jetzt endlich die Tür eingehen kann
bisschen rum gewackelt und direkt eine
Tür eine richtige Tür die man zu machen
kann die hält die man aufmachen kann
ohne die man jetzt reingehen kann oha
die Tür macht das ganze irgendwie vom
Gefühl also richtig fertig weil jetzt
nichts mehr offen ist und jetzt kommt
mein persönliches Highlight aufs Dach
und zwar die beiden Solarmodule von dem
ich jetzt einfach klappt und dann diese
Standfüße quasi aktiviere gerade nicht
mega senkrecht er hat natürlich noch in
die Richtung Sonne drin natürlich
Schlauch einmal der nächste soll ich
jetzt vorzugsweise da wo unter mir
Balken sind weil ich das Dach immer noch
ziemlich gruselig finde um ehrlich zu
sein
ja weit genug weg damit kein Schatten
wirft auf das andere
[Musik]
ich fühle mich jetzt ein bisschen
gescammt weil ich brauche für die
Verkabelung von den Solarpanels zum
powerhouse genau da in der Ecke irgendwo
ein Loch der ist einfach gar keinen Sinn
dass wenn man sich einmal die Wand
anschaut 1000 Löcher gar keinen Loch
so und da kommen jetzt dieses Kabel hier
durch so einfach angesteckt und dann
sieht man schon da kommt jetzt gerade
rein und zwar gerade über 200 Watt
obwohl vielleicht ist man kann übrigens
bis zu fünf von diesen Solar Generatoren
ans Power ausstecken na dann bist du
1.000 Watt Leistung würde ich das
Bauhaus in nur zweieinhalb Stunden voll
geladen ist wir haben jetzt auf jeden
Fall eine Klima neutrale Bruder und auch
das Bauhaus selbst ist so
umweltfreundlich gebaut wie möglich ohne
gefährliche Materialien wie Nickel oder
Kobalt und mit dem zuverlässigen über
3000 Ladezyklen das Lied zum
Eisenphosphat Akkus wird das
wahrscheinlich länger halten als die
Bude selbst an kann es sich damit der
Qualität Ihres Produktes übrigens so
sicher dass ihr euch fünf Jahre Garantie
geben
[Musik]
cooles Gartenhaus seinem Hintergrund ne
ja okay also ist jetzt fertig und wir
gehen jetzt einfach mal
reinkommen jetzt oder was
das funktioniert habe
auf jeden Fall genau und unser Plan war
eigentlich hier zu sitzen und eine
schöne Aussicht haben
ich glaube dass das im April wenn die
werden die Apfelbäume alle blühen
wir noch einige Pläne also auch
vielleicht irgendwie eine Dämmung
reinmachen damit sie nicht kalt oder
warm wird
Sachen ich bin richtig gespannt das wird
glaube ich richtig richtig cool Essen
Abendessen
[Musik]
bisschen Musik
vom 20 März bis 2 April gibt's bei Anker
wie gesagt bis zu 734 € Rabatt und wenn
ihr schnell seid könnt ihr bis zum 19
März noch bei der glücksradaktion
teilnehmen bei der ihr noch mal
zusätzlich bis zu 1.250 Euro und top als
Rabatt bekommen und dann ebenfalls
zwischen dem 20 märz und dem zweiten
April einlösen könnt